EVAN JONES: Hello everybody.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir.
I'm Evan Jones.
And with me--
JULIEN PHALIP: I am Julien.
EVAN JONES: And we're going
to be talking to you on one
of these webinars that you're
going to see every Tuesday--
we're excited to
kick off today's--
about getting the
most out of your data.
And this is from data to
insights with the Google Cloud
Platform.
This is ultimately going
to be a teaser or a preview
of a longer course
that you can take,
either on demand, or in
an in-person session.
So hopefully we'll get
you excited enough today
with some pretty cool
demos, three cool demos,
that we're going to show
you a little bit later.
You can ask a question
inside of the chat box.
And we have live
Googlers standing by.
So if you have a
question on the demos,
or a question about
the course materials,
or anything like that, just
type in your questions.
Even though we're
talking, you'll
have live Googlers answering
those for you as well.
So why don't you
say we get started?
JULIEN PHALIP: Let's do it.
EVAN JONES: All right.
So, first off, a
little about ourselves.
Who are these folks
here in front of you?
So you might have seen me
from some previous webinars.
I'm a technical
curriculum developer.
And for Google
Cloud, my specialty
is big data and
machine learning.
So topics like BigQuery or some
of the machine learning APIs
that you can access right
now, I like building super fun
courses out of them,
and then recording them
live on here for you to take.
But sometimes a lot
of people accuse me
of saying, well, you
might not necessarily
have the latest and greatest of
what there is out in the field.
So with me I brought
an amazing co-host.
And we have--
JULIEN PHALIP: So hi.
My name is Julien Phalip.
And I'm a solutions architect
here at Google Cloud.
My role is to work
with customers
and help them plan for the
migration of their workloads
to GCP.
I've lived in various
parts of the world,
in Reunion Island, France, and
Australia, as evidenced here
in a photo, mingling
with the locals.
And more recently I've moved
to San Francisco six years ago,
which is where I'm based now.
EVAN JONES: Cool.
JULIEN PHALIP: How
about we get started.
EVAN JONES: Yeah.
Let's do it, shall we?
JULIEN PHALIP: Let's do this.
EVAN JONES: You
definitely get points
for the more creative photos.
So let's talk a
little bit about what
we're going to cover today.
So you learned a
little bit about us.
And we're going to overview
what generally we're
going to cover right now.
So, as I mentioned,
this is going
to be big data and
machine learning focused.
And this is going to be
like a very high level
overview in the
slides, and then some
deeper dives into the demos
that we're going to do.
So it's going to
be three things.
You might have already
heard of BigQuery.
We're going to go into
a quick demo of that.
It's the ad hoc querying
processing platform.
And we have Cloud Dataprep.
And Julien's going to walk you
through a pretty cool demo,
if you're ever interested
in how to clean up
dirty data in a more
automated and GUI fashion.
And, last but not
least, we're going
to end with some machine
learning concepts.
So this is accessing machine
learning APIs in a friendly way
through a DataLab notebook
that I'm going to cover.
And all three of
these demos, and all
of the content behind them, is
covered in much more greater
detail in the course.
So hopefully this will
get you jazzed and excited
to launch and take that
Coursera course fully.
What do you say we get started?
JULIEN PHALIP: Let's do this.
EVAN JONES: Let's do it.
JULIEN PHALIP: All right.
So today companies face
a lot of pain points.
They have to deal with a huge
amount of structured data
and unstructured data.
Unfortunately, they
don't always have
the technical expertise
and the infrastructure
to process that data.
And then also, that data tends
to come in different forms
with varying levels of quality.
And that makes it difficult to
extract value from that data.
So as a result,
those insights tend
to be locked up in opaque data.
And it's also difficult to
share it amongst stakeholders.
So this is why companies tend to
miss out on huge opportunities
to expand their businesses.
And this is where Google
Cloud platform comes in.
Google Cloud Platform offers
a fully managed turnkey system
to visually explore,
clean, and prepare
structured data and
unstructured data
to analyze at scale with
minimal technical expertise.
As Evan just
mentioned, we're going
to run you through a few demos
of some of the products that
are available on our
platform, and to show you
how easy they are to operate.
EVAN JONES: All right.
So let's give this webinar
a little bit of a broader
context.
So today hopefully
you're coming here,
and you might have used SQL.
Or if you're not
familiar with how
to kind of ask
questions of your data,
you're in the right place.
We're going to demo from
the SQL side in BigQuery,
to the data cleansing
side in Dataprep,
to the machine learning side in
some of the DataLab notebooks
that we're going
to be working with.
So this is just generally
to get you primed
and ready to potentially jump
in and take that Coursera
course tomorrow.
And then later on there
if you wanted to say,
well, I really, really
enjoy these concepts,
and I'm really enthused to learn
more about machine learning.
What other courses do you
have on data engineering,
or application infrastructure,
or Kubernetes and container
deployment?
Those for the step
three, you can
take whatever tracks that
you want available on demand
through our Coursera
courses there,
or in-person training as well.
So you're at the start of
your journey, honestly.
So hopefully, at the end
of this, what you'll get
is just a little
bit of appreciation
for what some of the tools
and technologies on the Google
Cloud Platform can do.
But it's by no means the end.
So just to kind of kick off
this in general context,
a lot of folks ask,
well, all right, there's
a lot of tools and products
in the Google Cloud Platform.
What does Google do really well?
As you can see here from
the Forrester chart,
Google is a leader
in what I would
say are some of the current
offerings for big data
and machine learning
specifically.
So when folks are
asking, all right,
well, I want to get more
well-versed in the data space.
Where should I start?
So oftentimes they'll jump
into the Google Cloud Platform,
and then use a
tool like BigQuery.
Which, as you're
going to see, you
don't need to set up your
own server infrastructure.
You don't need to worry about
the scalability of adding
more hardware over time.
So you have like a
Black Friday sale.
And you're worried
about whether or not
the mass amounts of data that's
coming into your warehouse,
if you're going to have
to have a ton more servers
to query that type of data.
So it's serverless,
and a little bit
scalable to petabytes of data.
But a lot of times we get
faced with this blank stare.
So you walk into the
Google Cloud Platform.
And it's exactly that.
It's a platform with
many different products
and services.
And a lot of folks
don't necessarily
know which is the
best place to start.
So for this particular
webinar we're
going to focus in on
what you see directly
there in the middle,
which is going
to be your data and analytics.
So the reason why it's
called Google Cloud Platform,
cloud because it's scalable.
You don't need to worry about
the server's infrastructure
behind the scenes.
And platform, as you
see that bottom bar,
offers many different
products and services
that you can build on top of.
That's why it's
called the platform.
And then obviously we can't
cover all of those topics today
in just the short amount
of time that we have.
So me being completely
biased and really enjoying
the data and ML
ones, we're going
to jump into those six
icons that you see there.
First BigQuery, then Dataprep.
And then through
DataLab, we're going
be accessing those three machine
learning APIs on the right.
So as we covered,
we're going to take
a look at BigQuery,
Dataprep, and then
the machine learning APIs.
But it's best done
through real demos.
So let's go ahead
and jump right in.
BigQuery itself
answers the question
of how do I do data analysis?
I'm a business
intelligence professional.
How do I do data analysis
at scale in a meaningful way
without having to manage
servers or infrastructure?
And it deals with a lot
of the general problems
that you might see in
the day-to-day world.
So, for example, how do I get
tons of data in, petabytes
of data in?
Well, you can import
it into BigQuery.
How do I transform that
data in a repeatable way?
Well, you could do that either
through SQL and BigQuery,
or, as Julien's
going to show you,
inside of Cloud Dataprep with
some pretty fun wranglers.
How do you deal with storage?
How do you deal with the
analysis of the data?
And ultimately, how
do you visualize
the end of those results?
This is the day in
and day out life
of a data analyst or a business
intelligence professional.
And it's been my life
for the last 10 years,
getting folks excited about SQL.
But also in the last couple
of years, a lot more tools
that make data analysis, and
processing, and visualization
a lot easier, and arguably
a lot more fun, too.
So that said, it's demo time.
Let's jump into the
first demo, which
is going to be using BigQuery
to process over 10 billion rows,
about 500 gigabytes.
And we can test it to
see how fast it does.
So, first and
foremost, I'm going
to jump into Google BigQuery.
And, again, as
part of the course,
we're going to go through a
lot of the different bells
and whistles of the UI, and
where you can find things here.
But first and foremost,
all you have to know
is that you can write SQL,
which is the structured query
language that you ask questions
of your data, into this box
here.
So you write SQL queries
and you get answers back.
So in the simplest
case, how I normally
would teach the course,
is you say, all right,
well, give me, which is just a
fancy way of saying select, 5
and 5.
And, as you can see,
if you run the query,
you get 10 as a
result back there.
And you're saying, OK, wow.
Well, SQL and BigQuery
is nothing more
than a really big calculator.
And, yeah.
Well, that's true.
Extrapolate this.
Say you didn't have 5 and
5, but you added an order,
like the quantity
times the order.
But say you wanted
to actually pull data
from a particular table.
So I have this
pre-canned query that I'm
going to pull open here.
And what you're looking
at is a SQL query
that selects the
language, the article
title, and the total
number of views
that each of the pages
in Wikipedia has.
And not only does it do that.
But it filters for each
of the different pages
where the title--
you see the wild card
operator-- has Google somewhere
in the name.
So if you know
Wikipedia, you know
that there's tons, and
tons, and tons of pages
out there, millions, if not
billions, of different pages.
So let's see how
long it actually will
take to process all of these.
So I'm going to run this query.
And in addition to
pulling all those records,
it's doing these aggregations
behind the scenes.
And it's doing this
wild card operation
to see the titles where
it's matching Google.
And then it's showing the pages
that have the most views first.
Now, the most interesting
thing, yeah, the results
are down here.
But the thing about what
makes BigQuery BigQuery is
if you look here on
the right, you'll
see that in about
11 or 12 seconds
it processed through
416 gigabytes of data.
So massive amounts of data.
You just put your data
inside of BigQuery,
and then run these ad
hoc queries on top of it
without having to
worry about spinning up
database servers, or managing
software, or anything like that
behind the scenes.
Interesting.
It's also an exploration tool.
So if you wanted to see, well,
what are the other public data
sets that are available out
there inside of BigQuery,
you could see that,
all right, well, there
is some weather data from
NOAA going back to 1929,
and a bunch of other
publicly available data sets.
Because you might
say, all right, Evan,
I don't have a data set
that I can play around with.
Do you have example queries,
or do you have example data
that I can just
get a feel for what
are some of the different
things that I can do with SQL,
and what are the
different types of things
that I can do with the
data sources and data
sets that are out there?
So not only can you
query, but you can also
explore some of the
really cool data that's
available publicly, both
here inside the BigQuery UI.
And there's a great
team that manages
the BigQuery public data sets.
So if you just Google
BigQuery public data sets,
and we'll drop the
link into the bottom,
you can see a lot of
really cool data sets
that you can play around with.
All right.
So BigQuery, again,
you can ingest data.
You query it live,
really fast, with inside
of SQL that you write.
You're going to
learn more about what
are the different
types of advanced SQL
that you can do inside of
BigQuery inside of the course.
And, of course, you can run
your queries, save the results,
store the results.
All right.
And as you see
here, the results.
We have English for the
Google page that has--
let me do my counting here--
9 million views for
the English page.
We have the Spanish page there
for the second result there.
And you can imagine
that if you wanted
to change any part
of your query,
you just adjust the query here.
And you can return the new
results there, as well.
That's the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to BigQuery.
You re-execute queries.
One of the things that
I like to do almost
as a trick for the
students in the course
is if I reran it, do you think
it will run faster, or slower,
or the same speed?
A lot of people will say,
oh, it's the same, right?
Well, the good
news about BigQuery
is it'll actually store
your results, cached
behind the scenes where it can.
And this query, for example,
took three seconds cached.
And it didn't query
416 gigabytes of data,
because it had
already done that.
So it's a little
bit of intelligence
that's built in behind the
scenes inside the architecture.
I could go on and talk
at length about BigQuery.
But one of the
biggest things here
is that this Wikipedia
data was already loaded,
and more importantly,
already cleaned and cleansed.
Now, I guarantee you the
data that you have inside
of your organizations is
probably not only siloed
in different departments,
but it is also uncleaned.
So say the act of
preparing your data--
converting dates to
the right date format,
truncating fields--
that's often a pain to do,
especially by hand, or even
sometimes with SQL.
And we're going to see next
what a better way to cleanse
and explore that data is.
JULIEN PHALIP: All right.
Switching back to the slides.
So Cloud Dataprep.
As Evan just mentioned, to be
able to do valuable analytics
or machine learning
algorithms, you
need to have data
that's in a clean state.
You need that data to conform
to some integrated rules.
For example, the
data has to be valid.
One example is that
numbers have to fall
within the expected range.
Dates have to be
properly formatted.
Another example is
about completeness.
You want to make sure
that you have all the data
that you need.
If there are some
missing values,
you have to be able
to deal with that,
and maybe fetch the proper
information to complete
that data.
Uniformity is also
an important role.
You want to make sure
that, for example, numbers
are in the right unit so that
you can do proper calculations.
However, yes, it is true
that in the real world
it's very rare
that you are handed
a clean data set to begin with.
So that's why you have
to do some transformation
on that data to make it
cleaner so that then you
can do proper analytics or
machine learning work with it.
So this is where Cloud
Dataprep comes in.
Cloud Dataprep is Google's
self service data wrangling
tool, data wrangling being
the process of taking data
in its native format, and then
making it usable for analysis.
Dataprep is a UI based tool.
There is no need
to write any code.
And it's very easy to use.
So this is what I'm going
to show you now in a demo.
OK.
So what you can see
here on the screen
is a data set which I've just
loaded in Cloud Dataprep.
It is a data set of about a
million records of fake credit
card transactions.
Those are fake just for
the purpose of this demo.
And so I'm going to walk
you through the interface.
You can see here all of the
rows, all of the records.
And you can also see all of the
fields displayed on the screen.
Let's take a look at
the submission date
on the left, which is
the dates and times when
the transactions were made.
It looks like, if you look
at the histogram, which
show at what point in time
those transactions were made,
you can see two spikes there.
So that looks interesting.
What's something you can do is
to look in the details here,
in the current details,
to take a closer look.
And yes, indeed, you can see
that there are two spikes here,
two moments in time.
I don't know.
Maybe there was some marketing
campaign that happened.
We are already starting
to get some insight here.
It's something you might want
to look into further later on.
You can see also Dataprep
shows you more information,
like, for example, which day of
the week the data was recorded,
or which month of the year.
So, as you can see, you can
drill down into each column
and then get some more
details about that data.
Let's take a look at the
transaction amount column here.
What you can see here
at the top is what
is called the data quality bar.
It gives you some
information about the quality
of that particular column.
Here you can see, in particular,
there is a dark gray stripe.
That means that there
are some missing
values for some of the records.
If I click on this, you
will see that it actually
highlights all of the records
that have the missing value.
EVAN JONES: That's cool.
JULIEN PHALIP:
Something we can do,
maybe we can decide for the
purpose of our analytics work,
we want to remove
all those records.
And that's very easy to
do here on the right.
You can just select here Add for
the delete rows transformation.
And that's going to
automatically remove
all of the rows that
have the missing value.
And you can see now the
dark stripe is gone.
So for transaction
amount we are expecting
to see some decimal value.
So this is why I'm going
to change the type.
And now that we
changed the type,
you can see that
there is a red bar.
This means that some values
are mismatched or misformatted.
Let's take a closer look.
I'm clicking on that.
And that highlights all of the
incorrect or mismatched values.
Incorrect here.
There is also the dollar
amount right there.
So to be able to do some
calculation on those numbers,
we will need to remove
those characters.
And there, again,
this is something
we can do here by selecting
a transformation here.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to replace.
EVAN JONES: And these
are just suggestions
that automatically came up?
JULIEN PHALIP: Yeah.
These are just suggestions.
It will offer you
a few suggestions
of operations they
would typically do
based on the type of the
column that you've selected.
So here I've selected the
replace transformation.
And here there's
also something that's
really cool, is
that you can preview
the effect of your
transformation
in that yellow column
that just appeared.
So you can see that here,
yes, indeed, the USD character
would be removed.
However, we also need to
tweak that transformation
to also remove the dollar sign.
So this is what I'm going
to do here by clicking Edit.
And here in the pattern
that is [? matched, ?] I'm
going to select USD, as
well as the dollar sign.
And there you have it.
The dollar sign is also
going to be removed.
So now I can just add
this step in the recipe.
A recipe is basically a
series of transformation steps
that you want to
apply to a data set.
All right.
So now we've cleaned up the
transaction amount column.
Let's move on and look
at the transaction type.
The transaction
type column contains
the type of the transaction.
It could be a debit, or
credit, or an authorization.
Something that could be
useful in some cases,
for example in
machine learning, it's
useful to create features
that will extract
the different types of
the different values that
are available in the
particular column.
It's also useful for doing
aggregation calculation.
So something we can do here
is to split that column
into three separate
columns, one for each value.
So down here.
Oh, sorry.
I just clicked the wrong thing.
Try again.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE] click Create a
Column for Each Unique Value.
And there again, you
can see the preview
of what's going to happen.
It's going to insert a
Boolean, or a 1 or 0, one
for each value.
All right.
Moving on to the credit
card number column.
EVAN JONES: I'm furiously
writing all these down
so I can go online.
JULIEN PHALIP: Yeah.
So obviously that is pretty
sensitive information.
We might not want
our data scientists
to have access to
that information.
EVAN JONES: Everyone's
taking screenshots at home.
JULIEN PHALIP: Exactly.
Please don't.
This is just a fake
data set, anyway.
So you won't get
anywhere with that.
But yeah.
So this is a case
where Dataprep could
be used to remove
sensitive information.
So here what I'm
going to do, I'm
going to add a new
step in the recipe.
I'm going to type
replace to select
the replace transformation step.
Select the credit card column.
And then for the
pattern, I'm going
to select the first 12 digits.
And I'm going to say, replace
those digits with a few stars
at the beginning.
So that way we're sure
that those credit card
numbers are totally anonymized.
All right.
And then moving on
to the email field,
you see that there is
another red stripe here.
That means that some
of the email addresses
are misformatted.
So it's something we
might want our marketing
team to take a look at that
and maybe fix the issue.
So here what I'm
going to do, I'm
going to create a new
column with a flag.
And that flag is going to be
true for all of the values that
are misformatted.
And that way our
marketing team can just
follow up with our
users, and then
try and fix and get the
proper email address.
And then, finally,
the location field.
Here is the field that contains
two information, the latitude
and the longitude.
Those two information
are concatenated
in the same column.
It might be useful for
calculation purposes
to split those two values.
So this is also something
I'm going to do here.
I'm going to add a split
step for the location column.
And I'm going to split it using
the semicolon character, which
is the one that is used to
separate those two values.
So now that's going to create
those two extra columns.
And to make it easier
to work with that,
I'm going to rename
those columns,
the first one as latitude, and
the second one as longitude.
All right.
So now that we've
cleaned our data set,
we've basically
worked on a sample.
We want to apply that same
recipe of transformations
to the whole data set, to
the million records that we
have in our source data set.
So this is where you're
ready to run a job.
When you run a job, it's
going to use Dataflow
behind the scenes to run all of
those same transformation steps
at scale for your
entire data set.
You have the option
of outputting
the clean data set either to
cloud storage or to BigQuery.
So by default, it's going to
use a CSV file in cloud storage.
So here I'm going
to run the job.
And it will take a
few minutes to run.
EVAN JONES: This is on
the entire data set now.
JULIEN PHALIP: This is going
to run on your entire data set.
And you can see here,
the job is running.
Something that you
might also want to do
is to schedule these
same jobs to run
every hour, or every
minute, for every interval
that you want if you
expect to receive
fresh data from time to time.
So that was a quick
demo of Dataprep,
something that's very easy
to use to do transformation
on your data.
EVAN JONES: That's excellent.
Thanks, Julien.
I'm sure a lot of you folks,
as you were watching the demo,
had a lot of questions
about, well, can it do this?
What about this transformation?
Don't forget.
Type in your questions
into the box below.
And, again, we love these tools.
They were just as exciting
to us when they first
released as they are to
a lot of you seeing them
for the first time.
So add those questions in.
Try to stump the hosts here.
And we'll answer those
in the Q&A section.
All right.
Last demo on the board,
while that job is running,
let's jump back into a little
bit of machine learning.
So I would say Dataprep is
such a tough act to follow,
because I've been working
with SQL for 10 years.
And just seeing
the ease of which
you can do a lot of
those transformations,
and it handles the scheduling,
or the workflow component.
Even if you know a lot
of SQL, a lot of you
may be screaming, yes, finally
in the background, too.
So Cloud Dataprep is super
fun to play along with.
So the only thing
that I could do
to get the same level of
enthusiasm for that one
is introduce some
of the cool things
that you can do with what I
call friendly machine learning.
So friendly machine learning
means, if Google already
has the machine
learning APIs for things
like text classification,
redacting personally
identifiable information
automatically,
and they've had these
models already pre-trained,
how can you get
easy access to them?
So that's what we're
going to cover next.
Before we do that,
I just wanted to do
a little bit of an exercise.
Take a look at these two fruits.
Even without machine learning,
just think about heuristically,
how would you classify
them as one or the other?
So a lot of you
might be thinking,
OK, well, obviously I know,
just with my human intuition,
the one on the left is an apple.
The one on the
right's an orange.
One of them's red.
One of them's orange.
Let's classify them
based on color.
Not so easy.
So now what happens if
I gave you these images?
Now, what happens if
I added more fruit?
See, on the right you
have not only something
that's spherical in shape-ish.
A little bit oblong there.
That mango is also multi-color.
So when you're doing
these hard-coded rules,
or imagine building
a big decision
tree of if this fruit is
red, then this, or maybe
even if it has a stem,
you get into a very,
dare I say, like hard-coded
fashion of a ton of rules.
And that's maybe a
little bit too much
that you wanted to take on.
Well, let's start
with something easier.
How would you classify,
say, for example,
the difference between
this dog here and the mop?
It's very easy to
know the difference
between a dog and a mop, right?
That's going to be just like
one of those 0 and 1 things.
Oh, not so much.
It turns out there is
a lot of dogs out there
that look like mops.
So this is just
an example there.
So even for humans,
it's very hard.
Just sometimes that might seem
like an easy classification
task gets you quickly
into hot water.
And the good news
is, with machine
learning the
machines can pick up.
And they don't learn
these hard-coded rules.
So machine learning
is all about replacing
these hard-coded rules
or heuristic rules
with learned knowledge
from historical patterns
that they've seen.
So with Google
Photos, for example,
you feed in a ton
of images of dogs
and a ton of images of mops.
When I say a ton, like
millions of records, billions
of records of these images.
And then the
algorithms, the machine
learning models get smart enough
to then classify this as, say,
99% sure that this is
a dog and not a mop.
So the ultimate question there
is, how do you get access
to these friendly
machine learning models
where the training's
already been done?
You can use those five.
And that's just the
tip of the iceberg
for some of the
pre-trained ML APIs, those
five there on the right.
And that's what
we're going to demo.
Or if you're saying,
well, there's
not really a pre-trained
ML API for my use case,
that's when you
would use something
like TensorFlow or
the cloud machine
learning engine to write
your own model code,
and then train your own models.
But, again, the training
step for a model,
and, more importantly,
getting that really rich
historical data, is oftentimes
one of the hardest efforts.
And you can skip that
step almost entirely
by invoking or
using some of what
I'll call these friendly
machine learning APIs.
So let's look at
each of them in turn.
And then I'll show you
a web browser demo where
you can access them yourself.
And I'll show you
how you can actually
use that programmatically.
And begin to think about ways
that in your jobs-- maybe
you might not be working
with images, as you see here.
This is just a simple
classification.
I tried to trick the
model a little bit
with this camouflage owl.
Obviously it was able to
pick that up pretty quickly.
But say you have a lot of text.
So say you had customer
reviews, or product reviews,
and you wanted to mine that for
sentiment or a syntax analysis,
you can do that with the
Natural Language API, as well.
So I'm just going to
show you very quickly.
You don't have to do this now.
But if you're watching
this video again,
you could go to cloud.google.com
/naturallanguage,
as you see there in the browser.
And then you can say, Analyze.
And this is the browser
version, where you just have
text that's fed into there.
And the pre-trained
model behind the scenes
looks for different entities.
So basically it
says, oh, we think
Google is an organization
based on the text
that you inputted here.
Also, you're talking
about Android and users.
And this is about a customer
electronics show for Google.
And you can say, well, let's
rate the sentiment analysis.
Is it positive or negative?
And you can say,
from zero to one,
green being positive and closer
to one, and red being negative,
closer to negative one, this is
a slightly positive sentiment.
So Google, in this
particular case,
is announcing a new product.
So naturally the next question
is, all right, well, you're
showing me this inside
of a web browser demo.
How do I do that for
my data without having
to come back here and copy
and paste all of that text
at the same time?
And that's when I'm
going to introduce you
to one of the last tools
in the tool kit that's
covered as part of the course,
which is a data science
notebook, or DataLab is the
product of the notebook.
So if you're familiar with
IPython or Jupiter Notebooks,
this is going to
look familiar to you.
So inside of Google, inside of
Cloud DataLab, what I have here
is this ML APIs
IPython Notebook.
And this is going to be one
of the labs in the course
that you're going to take.
I'm actually going to reconnect.
And what you see here is a lab
that we've written for you.
And inside a lab notebook are
two different types of text
that you're going to see.
So if you're familiar with
SQL, inside of BigQuery,
just jumping over
there very quickly,
you'll see that it's
pretty much all code.
And then if you have a
very friendly developer,
you'll also have a
little bit of comments
that are thrown in there,
as well, if you're lucky.
Inside of Cloud
DataLab Notebooks,
I like to say that
it promotes code
commenting to almost like an
equal class as the actual code.
So you have these
cells that are code.
And then you have the cells
that are marked down, or pretty
much anything that you
would want to have,
like text, or links, or
something like that, too.
So it reads more like a story.
So if you've ever worried
about looking at code
and not understanding it,
Cloud DataLab Notebooks
will pretty much allow you
to tell a cohesive story
with one long notebook.
So our goal here is to play
around with a lot of machine
learning APIs that
are available.
So what I'm going to
do is, I have an API
key that's been authenticated.
The four APIs that are part
of this lab are listed here.
I'm only just going
to go through a few
so you can get a
familiarity with it.
So those of you familiar
with Google Translate,
we're just going invoke
the Google Translate
API with just a few
lines of code here.
And all of these labs
and all of these demos
are publicly available
in the course repository.
And so what I'd highly
encourage you to do,
don't focus on memorizing and
regurgitating verbatim the code
that you see here.
You can always start with
this notebook as a template,
and then swap out where the
data comes from to maybe
your own data sources, or play
around with them yourself.
So let's see.
If I wanted to convert
the data input,
this is using the service.
Is it really this easy, our
amazing technology here?
Wow.
Actually you can
just edit these.
I'm going to say, terrible.
And then I can just run
this particular code.
And then you see just
this section of code runs.
[INAUDIBLE] --And
it will come back
with a translation based
on the language inputs
that we've set in, which
in this particular case
we're sourcing it to
English, and hoping
for the target end
[INAUDIBLE] language in FR,
which is French.
Ah.
I need to reset my session.
Oh, perfect.
Now that we're reconnected,
I'm actually going to--
sometimes to conserve
resources, the DataLab notebooks
will pause, just to make
sure that they're not using
resources behind the scenes.
So sometimes what
you might have to do
is just reconnect the
current notebook session.
Let me just make sure
that Cloud DataLab--
Ah, the Cloud Shell.
All right.
So in the interest of
time, what I might do
is we'll save this
for a demo that I'm
going to upload a little
bit later, because I have
this a little bit pre-done.
And what I might do is we're
going to pause for questions
that you have, based on
what you've seen so far.
And while we pause, what I'm
going to do is just restart
this box.
And then we'll do the demo just
quickly after the sessions.
So if you haven't finished, type
in the questions that you want
answered there.
And then what we'll do is
we'll come back after a minute.
And then I'll fix this.
And we'll get you up and
running with some very
easy and friendly
machine learning.
We'll be right back.
All right.
Welcome back.
We have a lot of
awesome questions
that we can't wait to answer.
But to almost vindicate myself,
I'm going to do a quick demo.
What had happened is
my machine decided
to go to sleep
behind the scenes.
JULIEN PHALIP: This happens.
EVAN JONES: Yeah.
I love doing it
during a live demo.
But I'm going to get you a
little bit of familiarity
with some of the translations.
So let's see if we can't
translate amazing technology
with the technology
that you see here.
Is it really this easy?
Is it really this hard?
And let's translate
that into French.
We'll test our French here.
Difficile.
There you go.
My French.
JULIEN PHALIP: That's it.
I can vouch for it.
EVAN JONES: You
can vouch for it.
JULIEN PHALIP: It's correct.
EVAN JONES: So the
translation works.
And then what I really
like about these next few
is we optically
characterly recognize--
I just made that up, by the way.
We OCR this image here,
and then extract the text,
and then translate it
from different languages.
So for these
pre-trained ML models,
you can layer them on top
of each other, as well.
JULIEN PHALIP: Really cool.
EVAN JONES: So this is the
Vision API, where you run that.
The image it's just
serving from is
in Google Cloud Storage,
which you may already
be familiar with.
So you could have
your own JPEG that you
could switch into there.
It's recognizing all
the characters and parts
of the text there.
And then it prints out,
basically saying, hey,
this is the language.
This is the locale.
And then, all right.
Use that as an input
to then translate it.
So a lot of the best machine
learning models-- like you've
seen the ones where you
just point your phone.
Say you're visiting overseas
in China or something
like that, where
you're just pointing
your phone at the sign.
It actually uses multiple
machine learning models
behind the scenes.
In this case, we translated
it to please love and respect
hygiene to create a beautiful
water environment there.
Last but not least,
very quickly,
one of my favorite ones is we
have ingested some poetry here.
And we're looking
at whether or not
it's sentiment analysis positive
or sentiment analysis negative,
and the strong
magnitude based on that.
So this one is, to
succeed you must
have tremendous perseverance
and tremendous willpower.
So I'm expecting that one
to be very high magnitude,
which it is.
The polarity is one, which means
it's very positive, and very,
very strongly positive.
Whereas, let's say, this
last one, negative one.
When somebody you love dies
and you're not expecting it,
you don't lose her all at once.
You lose her in
pieces over time.
So I'm getting sad
thinking about that.
That's negative one.
And that's a decently
strong 0.4 magnitude.
And, again, these are just
these pre-canned examples
that we have here, just by
running these notebook cells.
Use these labs when
you take the course.
And I would say, feel free
to edit this at your leisure.
Add in your own text.
Connect to your
own data sources.
Because, as I like to
say, good artists copy.
Great artists steal
So steal with pride
when you see these demos and
a lot of the pre-canned code
that we have.
All right.
We have about five more minutes.
And we definitely want to
answer a lot of the questions
that you've been asking.
If you have questions
additionally
for this machine learning stuff
that you didn't get a chance
to ask and type in,
be sure-- this video
will persist for folks who
want to watch it later.
Add your questions
even after our talk.
All right.
We're going to jump
into the Q&A. All right.
Let's see if they've stumped us.
First question.
Would the result set in
cache inside of BigQuery
automatically get invalidated
if the data set changes?
Somebody has definitely
played with BigQuery,
and that's absolutely true.
So cache is invalidated any time
the underlying data changes.
And the cool thing is, there's
a lot of metadata associated
with your tables inside
of BigQuery, where
you can actually look to
see when the table was
last updated or last modified.
And you can actually query that
particular metadata, as well.
I can speak more at length.
Take the course.
We go into some pretty cool
performance characteristics
in cache.
Let's see.
Do you want to
take the next one?
JULIEN PHALIP: Yeah.
I guess I could take that.
Can you record these
transformation suggestions
desired to be able to apply
to subsequent sets of data?
Yes.
The answer is yes.
Those steps are
recorded in the recipe.
And you can apply the
same steps to whatever
data set that you want.
EVAN JONES: Yeah.
And super useful if
you're collaborating
with other people,
you can actually
commit your recipe to version
control or something like that,
and basically have recorded
versions of recipes
as the recipes evolve
themselves over time.
All right.
Do you want to take
the Dataprep one?
JULIEN PHALIP: A quick
question for Dataprep.
We have data persisted
in multiple tables.
Can Dataprep run
on top of BigQuery
so that we can pull data
from across different tables?
The answer is yes.
You can not only pull data
from BigQuery, but also
from multiple tables.
You can mix and match
data, coming either
from cloud storage on BigQuery.
And you can join those
data sets together.
So yeah.
The answer is absolutely yes.
EVAN JONES: All right.
When data arrives
periodically, can you
automate such data
wrangling programmatically
instead of the UI?
So you have potentially
a data engineer here.
JULIEN PHALIP: Yeah.
So Dataprep is a UI driven tool.
If the transformations
available in Dataprep
aren't enough for the
purposes of the work
you have to do on
your data set, then
this is where you want
to use DataFlow instead.
DataFlow is the back
end behind Dataprep,
which allows you to write down
code that's much lower level,
but you also have
much more control
to write very specific
transformations.
So yeah.
The answer is that if
those transformations are
very specific, you would
want to use DataFlow instead.
EVAN JONES: Great.
How long does a Dataprep
job usually take?
JULIEN PHALIP: It
depends on the size
of the data set, the
complexity of the recipe,
and the transformation.
The job that I just ran
earlier took about 10 minutes.
So just to give you an idea.
EVAN JONES: Great.
When would you use--
I think you answered
this in part--
Dataprep versus using
something like DataFlow?
JULIEN PHALIP: So
Dataprep I would
use for exploration
purposes, 'cause
you already start getting
some visual insights
about your data.
You can play around.
And you can preview the effect
of your transformations.
And sometimes it's
actually enough to do
simple transformations.
And, again, if you have
more complex, more specific
or granular transformation
you want to do,
then this is where you
want to use DataFlow.
EVAN JONES: Cool.
Last but not least, what are
the performance considerations
for BigQuery data sets?
So we have an entire module
of the course dedicated
to making your queries
high performance
and making your data
sets high performance.
But just off the top
of my head, anytime
you're doing
transformations, make
sure you're only using
the data that you actually
want to transform.
That means if you
can filter your data
with a where clause early,
filter early and filter often.
Also, if you're a beginner
to intermediate SQL,
there are some really
advanced SQL concepts
that we go through in
detail inside the course,
like un-nesting or nesting
data, where you can actually
have a table that has inside
of it to drill down records.
So if you have a
customer, and then you
have all the orders
associated with them,
normal relational
database schema
would say, separate the two.
But inside of BigQuery,
you can actually
store parent-child records
within the same table.
And you get the
performance benefits
of automatically
pre-joining the tables
without having to do an
expensive SQL joint operation.
If that went way over your
head, take the course.
There's a lot of really, really
good topics on performance.
We go into Dataprep
in a lot more detail.
And yeah, I think you'll
honestly have a blast.
I think we have a more
links to show just
for folks who are
interested in grabbing the--
so this is the final slide that
we'll just show for you all.
So this is to access
Coursera courses.
This is to take
those Qwiklabs, which
are those labs that you
saw us going through
in those notebooks
automatically.
And last but not
least, if you wanted
to see what all the other
courses are that are available,
that last link is there.
But the good news is, this is
just the start of your webinar
series today.
So although we
kicked it off today
with just three of
the different tools,
be sure to stay tuned for
the next session, which
is Cloud ML Engine 101.
And we're going to put
you over live to Kirkland.
See you guys later.
Nice job.
JULIEN PHALIP:
Thanks for tuning in.
Bye.